qui était vit un moment très important
dans la lutte contre les violences de
l'intimé violence de la maison il y à
chaque année 300 mille personnes
victimes de violences sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
la transition aux manifs et l'objet
d'une réunion des dirigeants ouest
africains hogan la france elle pourrait
retirer ses troupes si le mali va dans
le sens d'un islamisme radical
avertissements d'emmanuel mapon dans le
conte à vue dimanche alors que le pays a
déjà subi deux coups d'état la situation
sécuritaire est également fragile cinq
personnes ont été tuées ce dimanche dans
une attaque menée par des djihadistes
présumés dans le sud du pays les
dizaines de milliers de personnes ont
manifesté hier dans plusieurs villes du
brésil d'une manifestation contre le
président j'ai à bolsenheim et sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire aux
voisines la pandémie a fait plus de 461
il mort c'est le pays le plus touché
après les états unis
[Musique]
prolonger de deux mois en raison de la
crise sanitaire la trêve hivernale prend
fin mardi à l'appel de plusieurs
associations dont le droit au logement
une manifestation a eu lieu à paris pour
protester contre les expulsions
locatives
plus de trente mille foyers sont
concernés
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france avant de
développer ses titres sachez qu en
israël naftali bennett le chef du parti
de droite radicale annonce qu'il
souhaite travailler avec le camp de
l'opposant yaïr lapid ce dernier tente
de rallier une coalition pour former un
nouveau gouvernement mais sans benyamin
nétanyahou pour le premier ministre
israélien cette alliance est en danger
pour la sécurité de l'état
je vous le disais en titre au mali cinq
personnes ont donc été tué tôt ce matin
dans une attaque menée par des
djihadistes présumés contre un poste de
contrôle dans le sud du pays une région
normalement plus épargnée par les
attaques terroristes la situation au
mali préoccupe moins d'une semaine après
un deuxième coup d'état une situation
qui pose à nouveau la question d'un
retrait de l'armée française cinq mille
soldats sont engagés au sahel au sein de
l'opération barkan dans un entretien au
journal du dimanche emmanuel macron
menace de retirer ses troupes si le mali
se dirige vers un islamisme radical chef
d'état français affirme le site qu'il ne
resterait pas au côté d'un pays où il ya
plus de légitimité démocratique ni de
transition emmanuel macron met aussi en
garde contre un échec de la politique de
développement en afrique
nous venions secours et en soutien d'un
état souverain pour qu'il ne soit pas
déstabiliser ou envahies par des
groupements rebelles et armée
je le dis avec lucidité si on est
complice de l'échec de l'afrique
on aura des comptes à rendre mais on le
paiera cher aussi notamment sur le plan
migratoire et c'est dans ce contexte que
cet après midi les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de la cedeao la communauté
des états de l'afrique de l'ouest sont
réunis en sommet extraordinaire à accra
au ghana
parmi les invités le colonel assainies
gorrite à à l'origine des deux coups
d'état du pays est désormais
officiellement en président du mali théo
combes
c'est un coup d'état dans le coup d'état
que la cedeao n'avait pas vu venir le
retour au pouvoir du colonel
jusqu'ici vice président de la
transition ah si meego et à cette
organisation qui regroupe une partie des
pays d'afrique de l'ouest se réunit
aujourd'hui en sommet extraordinaire à
accra seul sujet à l'ordre du jour
le mali face au putsch mené lundi
l'institution régionale a d'abord
vivement est officiellement dénoncé la
prise de pouvoir des militaires
un communiqué commun signé avec l'union
africaine et d'ailleurs publié dès le 24
mai une transition avec un gouvernement
civil et de nouveau réclamé ainsi que la
tenue rapide de nouvelles élections
pourtant depuis mardi et la visite du
médiateur de la cedeao au mali
l'organisation se fait beaucoup plus
discrète
signe d'une volonté d'apaisement avec le
nouvel homme fort du pays
ah si meego utah est invité à accra
depuis samedi afin de rencontrer divers
officiels membres de la cedeao
l'institution dont les relations avec
l'ancien président du conseil de
transition destitué bas ndo n'était pas
au beau fixe
evit ar et imposé des sanctions à un
pays dont l'économie est exsangue et la
population éprouvée comme la france la
cedeao pays sa mansuétude à l'égard d'un
autre pays du sahel le tchad et son
conseil militaire de transition au
pouvoir depuis le 20 avril dernier une
potentielle différence de traitement qui
pourrait être mal perçu au mali un
imbroglio politique dans une zone où la
menace djihadiste est toujours présente
des organisations terroristes qui
pourraient profiter de cette situation
chaotique
quelle est la position de la cedeao face
à la situation au mali décryptage
d'amadou 7 jobard il est professeur de
philosophie et auteur du livre et c'est
sur la fondation politique de la guinée
sont aussi face à une cedeao qui a du
mal à concevoir une transition
authentique et politique qui irait dans
le sens d'une refondation de l'état
malien en tout cas de sorte à le faire
d'un état capable de relever le défi de
justice et l'égalité politique parce que
nous sommes dans une conception de la
transition qui fait des élections
présidentielles l'objectif de la
transition et depuis d'ailleurs le coup
d'état de doute on voit que nous sommes
dans une une vision où on s'intéresse
simplement à ce que les civils retourne
au pouvoir alors que la transition n'est
pas simplement lié à une question
électorale
elle est aussi dit aux causes qui
conduisent ajustements à l'effondrement
des états en afrique et principalement
au mali donc il ya là quelque part une
déception de voir que la cedeao à la
fois sous légitimité politique mais
aussi n'a pas une conception authentique
de la transition politique
mobilisation en ethiopie contre les
sanctions imposées par les etats-unis à
la suite du conflit débuté il ya sept
mois aux tigres et des dizaines de
milliers d'éthiopiens on manifestent
leur mécontentement dans un stade
d'addis abeba la capitale un
rassemblement pro gouvernementale pour
dénoncer ce qui est perçu comme une
ingérence américaine où washington
accusent les autorités éthiopiennes de
violations des droits de l'homme dans la
guerre aux tigres et des sanctions
financières ont été imposées à des
officiels éthiopiens les etats-unis
comptent également faire pression sur le
fonds monétaire international pour geler
des financements les protestataires
estiment ce sanction injuste et
illégitime
[Musique]
je suis sorti aujourd'hui pour m'opposer
à l'idée de pays étrangers qui tente de
s'immiscer dans nos affaires intérieures
et de nous materner nous avons un pays
souverain en tant que pays souverain
notre peuple et notre gouvernement
décide pour notre pays
au moins la massane
l'ethiopie mon pays ira de l'avant et ne
reviendra pas en arrière
l'amérique devrait retirer ses mains et
l'egypte devrait s'abstenir de
construire le barrage du nil nous
voulons leur montrer que nous étions
obtient continueront en tant que nation
[Musique]
nouvelle manifestation anti gr ball
sonar ou au brésil des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont défilé hier
dans plusieurs villes du pays pour
exiger la destitution du président élu
lui reprochent sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire l'épidémie a fait plus de 461
mille morts dans le pays
les précisions avec media escaffit un
élan de colère au brésil alors que le
bilan épidémie continue de s'alourdir
avec 60000 nouvelles contaminations
recensés en moyenne chaque jour ce
samedi des dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé dans plusieurs
villes du pays majoritairement issus de
mouvements étudiants et d'organisations
de gauche il dénonce la gestion de la
pandémie par derrière bolt sonar où nous
avons décidé de descendre dans la rue
même à cette heure je pense qu'il n'y a
pas d'autres moyens nous devons
descendre dans la rue
donc si nous sommes dans la rue il est
important de porter des masques d'avoir
un jeune alcoolisé de garder nos
distances afin de pouvoir dire qu'il est
possible d'être dans la rue dans ce
contexte car nous ne pouvons pas rester
chez nous ces manifestants réclament le
départ du chef d'état brésilien
un président qui au début de la pandémie
qualifié le coït 19 de grippette
critiquer régulièrement le principe du
confinement et remettaient en doute
l'efficacité des sérums antico vide
mais face à l'ampleur de la crise
sanitaire sur le sol brésilien
wolson araud a dû revoir sa copie
notamment sur la question des vaccins
le brésil devrait recevoir dont les
premiers jours de juin plus de 2,3
millions de doses de vaccins files
heures biotech
avec cela nous dépasserons les 5,2
millions de vaccins du fabricant
malgré cet infléchissement l'attitude de
bolton arrow est toujours vivement
critiquée par les protestataires qui
estiment que les dégâts auraient été
moins important si cette stratégie avait
été adoptée en amont nous devons arrêter
ce gouvernement nous devons arrêter ce
bol sonar ou est un génocidaire c'est un
meurtrier c'est un psychopathe il n'a
pas de sentiments il ne ressens pas
comme nous il n'est pas capable de
percevoir le désastre qu'ils causent
[Musique]
avec plus de 460 mille morts liés aux
copies de 19
le brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé derrière les etats unis
conséquences politiques de cette gestion
de la crise sanitaire
le taux de popularité du président est
tombée à 24%
d'après un sondage de l'institut
datafolha soit son plus bas niveau
jamais atteint
cette étude révèle également que 49 %
des brésiliens sont favorables à sa
destitution
une situation plus que jamais
inquiétante pour des herbes also know à
16 mois de l'élection présidentielle
chercheur à l'iris spécialiste de
l'amérique latine jean jacques
kourliandsky revient sur l'évolution des
manifestations anti-wall sonar ou au
brésil ces manifestations sont
organisées par l'opposition
essentiellement à l'opposition de gauche
dans un contexte où l'établissement
brésilien économiques financiers et
politiques traditionnels chouette
également le départ de jaillir ball
solaro qui se révèle qui s'est révélé
incapable de gérer la crise sanitaire
au nom de la perpétuation du maintien
d'une activité économique permettant à
la population de continuer à travailler
mais en réalité c'est l'inversé qui
s'est produit
et on assiste actuellement à des
fermetures de grandes entreprises au
départ de cadres étrangers
donc il y à une convergence entre un
regain de la gauche qui est porté par la
libération de l'ancien président lula et
l'opposition croissante de
l'institutionnalité brésilienne
on reste en amérique du sud direction la
colombie ou le président et van dyck et
a décidé de déployer l'armée dans la
ville de cali épicentre des
manifestations anti gouvernementales
elles ont fait au moins 13 morts ce
vendredi
la haute commissaire de l'onu aux droits
de l'homme appellent aujourd'hui à une
enquête indépendante
un mois maintenant que la mobilisation a
commencé initialement contre un projet
de réforme fiscale qui a finalement été
abandonnée mais la colère ne s'estompe
pas amaya soubelet une période marquée
par la colère sociale
un bilan humain de plus en plus lourd et
des milliers de militaires qui prennent
possession du pays
les habitants sont partagés entre le
sentiment de sécurité et la crainte
d'une présence armée dans les rues
on m'a tiré dessus quatre fois sur les
côtés je pouvais entendre les balles
siffler dans mon oreille l'armée quelque
chose que les gens ont toujours respecté
et on se sent en sécurité avec eux
secoué par des manifestations
anti-gouvernementales quasi quotidiennes
la colombie connaît une répression
meurtrière qui a causé la mort de près
de 60 personnes
un mouvement initialement pacifique qui
a dégénéré au fil des jours face à une
situation hors de contrôle
le président ivan bouquet a ordonné le
déploiement de l'armée dans la troisième
ville du pays à popayan il a décidé
d'augmenter les effectifs militaires de
la ville la seconde pour badiane elle
ajouté mme ans des as ces derniers jours
la ville de popayan a connu de graves
actes de vandalisme de pillage et de
terrorisme urbain de faible intensité
nous avons ouvert la voie pour
accueillir pleinement cette assistance
militaire dans la ville de popayan et
dans le département en précisant que
pour la ville de popayan il va y avoir
une augmentation de 25% des effectifs de
l'armée pour accompagner l'assistance
militaire initialement dirigées contre
une réforme fiscale du gouvernement
la vague de contestations déferle depuis
maintenant en moi sur la colombie les
manifestants dénoncent désormais la
répression des forces de l'ordre contre
ce soulèvement social malgré le retrait
rapide de ce projet par ivan touquet la
mobilisation s'est poursuivie les
citoyens dénonce notamment l'attitude
des autorités colombiennes
après avoir tiré sur la foule et causé
la mort de deux civils à cali un
enquêteur a été tué par des manifestants
ce vendredi selon le parquet
des manifestations quotidiennes qui se
déroule généralement dans le calme et
qui dégénère au coucher du soleil
ce scénario semble n'en plus finir
depuis le 28 avril dernier
le mouvement contestataire sans
précédent bloque une partie des
activités de la colombie et provoquent
de nombreuses pénuries
à cela s'ajoute une crise sanitaire qui
plonge un peu plus le pays dans le chaos
autre titre de cette édition en france
trente mille foyers modestes ne
bénéficieront plus de la trêve hivernale
dès mardi ils pourront être expulsés par
les propriétaires même si la ministre du
logement souhaite que ces expulsions
soient adaptées au cas par cas
la trêve hivernale a été prolongée de
deux mois en raison de la crise
sanitaire manifestation s'est déroulée
cet après-midi à paris pour dénoncer les
expulsions elle a eu lieu à l'appel
d'une quarantaine d'associations dont le
droit au logement notre reporter le cas
légers a suivi cette manifestation les
manifestants ont défilé entre le
cimetière du père lachaise et la place
de la république où une partie des
centaines des migrants qui les
accompagnaient ont peut être pris en
charge dans des bus les autres ont
attendu ici sur la place de la
république qu'une solution soit trouvée
pour eux
les manifestants à l'appel du dal se
sont rassemblés pour demander au
gouvernement de renoncer à la fin de la
trêve hivernale les expulsions doivent
recommencer
en juin ils veulent que l'état trouve
des solutions pérennes notamment la
construction de hlm je vous propose
d'écouter jean baptiste eyraud du dal
que j'ai pu interroger au début de cette
manifestation
madame wagon a autorisé les expulsions
le dit nous on dit pas qu'il faut
expulser on dit qu'il faut suspendre les
expulsions et éventuellement relogés
préalablement à l'expulsion des
personnes pour lesquelles il ya vraiment
nécessité pour les raisons qu'on a
évoqué ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point lundi par relogement des
personnes elle dit relogement ou un
hébergement
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle va héberger
parce qu'on sait très bien aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus suffisamment de logements
sociaux plus suffisamment d'attribution
on est en situation de baisse on va dire
des des attributions possible
heureusement sociale et de
d'effondrement de la production de
logements sociaux avec ces manifestants
plusieurs personnes inquiètes pour leur
futur je vous propose d'écouter quelques
témoignages que j'ai pu recueillir au
début aussi de cette manifestation
j'ai eu peur d'être à la rue j'ai peur
de plus avoir de travail de plus et là
je suis dans une situation où ça va
remonter
ça y est décédé confiance je serai en
moyen de 2 des purées la dette de 2,2 me
remettre à zéro est remonté et n'est ce
pas il me laisse pas le
pour l'instant elle n'est ce pas l'heure
il n'est ce pas la place quoi ce que
vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est ça concerne
tous ces gens là y compris ceux qui
depuis très très longtemps n'ont pas
trouvé de logement
c'est déplorable de voir des gens comme
mon cas parmi d'autres que je suis
toujours dans la rue soit à l'auberge
soit les amis de gauche à droite et que
par naïveté ou par autres afin frappé
des doubles faces des portes
il n'y a pas d'entente la ministre
manuel wargon veut qu'il n'y ait
personne à la rue à l'issue de ces
expulsions et que les préfets se
focalise sur les cas qui posent le plus
de problèmes notamment pour les
bailleurs qui ont besoin de l'argent des
loyers pour vivre des indemnités sont
aussi prévues mais toutes ses promesses
et bien ici elle ne convainquent pas et
les manifestants sont inquiets pour les
trente mille foyers qui sont concernés
par cette fin de trêve hivernale
on revient sur la crise sanitaire pour
évoquer la situation dans les pays
d'asie il faisait figure de bon élève
dans la lutte contre la pandémie
il rencontre aujourd'hui des difficultés
avec leurs stratégies de vaccination
inquiétudes renforcées par la découverte
au vietnam d'un nouveau variant qui se
transmet rapidement dans l'air le point
sur la situation avec quentin voeckler
les autorités vietnamiennes font état
d'un nouveau variant sur leur territoire
ce samedi il s'agirait d'une combinaison
entre les mutations britannique et
indienne nous avons découvert un variant
hybride combinant le virus indien et le
britannique
sa caractéristique principale est qu'il
se transmet rapidement dans l'air
la concentration du virus dans la gorge
et la salive augmente rapidement et il
se répand très vite dans l'environnement
proche
jusqu'à présent le vietnam n'a été que
très peu touchée par la pandémie
cette première flambée épidémique a
commencé au début du mois de mai en
thaïlande l'épidémie de kovy 19 inquiète
dans les prisons où le virus se répand
ces dernières semaines plus de 25 mille
détenus ont été testés positifs
conséquence les prisonniers doivent
porter un masque de jour comme de nuit
cette hausse des contaminations met en
lumière la surpopulation des prisons
thaïlandaise
les détenus sont parfois obligés de
dormir entassés les uns sur les autres
en février le ministre de la justice
thaïlandaise déclaré aux médias locaux
c'est moins de place que pour un corps
dans un cercueil fin de citation la
thaïlande fait face à une résurgence de
l'épidémie depuis le début du mois
d'avril la plupart des cas de
contamination et des décès liés aux
covit 19 ont été recensés ces dernières
semaines comme le vietnam et la
thaïlande
l'ensemble des pays d'asie du sud est
font face à une flambée épidémique
depuis avril et personne ne semble y
échapper
le retour du virus est la conséquence
directe du retard pris par la
vaccination
toute la région félicité pour sa gestion
de la pandémie grâce notamment à des
mesures drastiques l'asie du sud-est a
raté le train de la vaccination à par
singapour et le cambodge
aucun des pays de la région mena
vacciner totalement plus de 4 % de sa
population
le programme onusien kovacs défaillant
le vietnam ou encore l'indonésie se sont
retrouvés en difficulté
de son côté la thaïlande a trop compté
sur le sérum d'astrazeneca problème il a
été limité aux plus de 50 ans en raison
de rares cas de thrombose
singapour est le seul bon élève de la
région en termes de vaccination avec
plus de 36 % de la population ayant reçu
une dose et 27% entièrement vacciner le
territoire montre l'exemple en asie du
sud est au venezuela face à une deuxième
vague épidémique le pays accélère sa
campagne de vaccination elle est
désormais ouverte aux plus de 60 ans une
campagne qui a débuté fin février avec
les vaccins russe spoutnik v et chinois
sinopharm yamina benguigui da les
piqûres sont chaîne dans cet hôtel de
caracas transformés en centres de
vaccination les vénézuéliens affluent
pour recevoir le vaccin rue spoutnik v
après avoir vacciné le personnel médical
les autorités les corps de sécurité et
les enseignants c'est désormais au tour
des personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans et
bien j'ai reçu le message au téléphone
ce matin et je suis venu tout de suite
ça ne m'a pas pris une demi heure pour
venir ici je suis venu et c'est tout
je ne suis même pas rester une heure ici
c'était rapide tout a été rapide
franchement je l' ai découvert parce que
ma mère qui à presque 90 ans a reçu un
sms sur son téléphone portable et
ensuite nous sommes venus la chercher et
la fille ici était très attentionné
on m'a dit qu'il fallait en profiter
parce que je suis déjà vieux
et puis j'ai dit ok allons-y
l'infirmière m'a tout facilité comme la
préparation de la carte
elle m'a tout facilité et je me suis dit
bien profitons-en
je pensais que ça allait être très
compliqué une nouvelle qui intervient
alors que le pays connaît depuis mars
une deuxième vague de contamination 22
centres comme celui ci ont été mises en
place le gouvernement projette d'en
ouvrir 77 à travers le pays
objectif atteindre 22 millions de
vaccinés en décembre et l'immunité
collective une accélération de la
vaccination possible avec l'arrivée le
23 mai d'un 1,3 million de vaccins
chinois des doses supplémentaires sont
attendus via le programme kovacs de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
ce moment après avoir payé toute la
location demandé par kovacs nous sommes
déjà en train de sélectionner les choix
possible de vaccins nous avons une
option qui est la plus plausible
le vaccin johnsen de johnson johnson si
cette société alou prochainement un lot
important de vaccins mécanisme kovacs
nous espérons que la cobac snooze
allouera un certain nombre de vaccins
pour les apporter également au venezuela
selon le gouvernement 11,3 millions de
vaccins pourrait pas revenir au
venezuela
cet été dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images les
chypriotes grecs et liste aujourd'hui
leurs députés dans la partie sud de
l'île où la république de chypre membre
de l'union européenne exerce son
autorité le scrutin se déroule dans un
contexte particulier notamment après la
révélation de la sphère des passeports
d'or ce sont donc des électeurs en
colère contre les pratiques de
corruption et de blanchiment d'argent
qui se rendaient aux urnes
quatorze étudiants et membres du
personnel d'une université du nord du
nigeria ont été relâchés hier par leurs
ravisseurs leur enlèvement remonter au
20 avril dans les jours qui ont suivi
leur kidnapping
cinq étudiants avaient été exécutés en
moyen de faire pression en vue
d'éventuelles aux grands sont au moins
deux personnes tuées et 20 blessées la
nuit dernière lors d'une fusillade dans
la banlieue de miami en floride selon la
police locale trois hommes ont tiré sur
la foule devant une salle de concert la
police a lancé un appel à témoins pour
identifier et localiser les tireurs le
motif des crimes n'est pas encore
établie et on reste aux états unis où
cette semaine a été marquée par une
commémoration mardi un an après la mort
de georges floyd étouffé sous le genou
du policier derek chauvine filmé la
scène avait fait le tour du monde et
suscité une vague d'indignation
yamina benguigui da le 25 mai 2000 vin
d'orge floyd un afro américain de 46 ans
meurt par asphyxie à minneapolis
l'homme a été victime d'une technique
d'immobilisation policière derek
chauvine le policier maintien
l'interpeller au sol en appuyant avec
son genou sur sa nuque
pendant près de 9 minutes dès le
lendemain des manifestations
s'organisent au cri de blake lively mada
malgré le limogeage des quatre policiers
impliqués
elle gagne plusieurs villes américaines
art de new york los angeles ou encore la
capitale washington
face à ces contestations donald trump
alors président des états unis promet de
stopper la violence collective
ils dénoncent les agissements de
gauchistes radicaux et menace de
déployer l'armée
la mort de joe wright provoque un
mouvement mondial
il devient le symbole de la lutte contre
les violences policières et le racisme
systémique le mouvement black lips
matters prend une ampleur internationale
calcio après trois semaines d'un procès
hors-norme des règles ovine est reconnu
coupable le 20 avril 2021 du meurtre de
george floyd l'ex-policier encourt douze
ans et demi de prison sa peine sera
prononcée le 25 juin prochain des
conditions aggravante demandé par le
procureur pourrait alourdir sa sentence
[Musique]
la sphère georges floyd a bouleversé la
politique américaine en mars dernier la
chambre des représentants à majorité
démocrate a adopté la loi de georges
floyd qui vise à réformer la police
le texte prévoit l'interdiction des
prises d'étranglement de rendre
obligatoire la collecte de données sur
les interventions de la police ou encore
de financer des programmes de police de
proximité
toutefois le projet n'a pas encore été
adopté par le sénat
l'année dernière déjà un projet
similaire avait été rejetée par le sénat
à majorité républicaine
ce schéma pourrait se reproduire cette
année les républicains affirment que ces
mesures pourraient empêcher la police de
faire son travail efficacement
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
après six mois de fermeture commerce non
essentiels terrasse ou encore cinéma ont
rouvert leurs portes le 19 mai lors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux déjà on a beaucoup
d'endroits beaucoup d'endroits se
retrouve les équipes de reprendre un
rythme avec quelques restrictions qui
sont délicates pour travailler
correctement les projections de
croissance etc c'est exceptionnel
on a eu je doute qu'elles soient
réalisées aussi facilement que ça il va
falloir quand même avoir une vision de
relance une vision d'accompagnement que
plus gros on navigue presque un petit
peu a vu quand les aides vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable